Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. It's the 27th of December, and so we continue with our 12 or maybe even 13 days of Christmas. And Dominic, your choice of an anniversary for the 27th of December, I think it's a very seasonally appropriate one, isn't it? Because it's themed around port. It is is themed around port so lots of people like port
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天是12月27日，我们将继续我们的“圣诞十二日”（或者甚至是十三日）特辑。多米尼克，你为12月27日挑选的周年纪念日，我觉得非常符合这个季节的氛围，不是吗？因为它的主题是波特酒。没错，主题就是波特酒，所以很多人喜欢波特酒
for christmas and well hangovers doesn't it no i think that's quite wrong i just smell port and i get a hangover so i think you can drink a lot of port and not get my brother once drank an entire bottle of port while having a bath did he well he presumably didn't drown in his bath no he i think it was a bottle of white port he told me and he said he got out of the bath and he felt great and then dr johnson say the port was the drink for heroes or something something like well we're going to come on to drinkers uh i've got some good facts about port drinkers later on so port very popular in england of course in britain uh not so popular elsewhere not so popular in the states and whatnot although i think it's taking off a little bit but why why
用来过圣诞节，还有宿醉，不是吗？不，我觉得完全不对。我只要闻到波特酒的味道就会宿醉，所以我觉得你可以喝很多波特酒而不会……我弟弟有一次在洗澡时喝了一整瓶波特酒。真的吗？嗯，他大概没有在浴缸里淹死吧。没有，我想那是一瓶白波特酒，他告诉我的，他说他从浴缸出来后感觉好极了。然后塞缪尔·约翰逊博士说波特酒是英雄的饮料，还是什么类似的话……嗯，我们待会儿会谈到饮酒者——我稍后有一些关于波特酒饮酒者的有趣事实。所以波特酒在英国当然非常受欢迎，在其他地方却没那么受欢迎，在美国等地的受欢迎程度也不高，尽管我觉它正在开始流行。但是，为什么
is it so popular in britain england do you know tom is it our old alliance with portugal it kind of is so it comes back to something that happened on the 27th of december 18 18 1703 um which is called the methuen treaty so we're in the war of spanish succession so one of the kind of endless wars that we fought between the sort of mid-17th century and the late 18th century well waterloo with france basically war for you know it's like a colossal world war isn't it i suppose um and portugal has actually been allied with the french believe it or not what so yes i know i thought they were allies this is we i know we have some portuguese listeners and perhaps they can explain themselves it's shocking behavior if they're members of the rest is history club they should declare
它在英国、在英格兰如此受欢迎呢？你知道吗，汤姆？是因为我们与葡萄牙的古老同盟吗？某种程度上确实是。所以这要追溯到1703年12月27日发生的一件事，嗯，被称为《梅休因条约》。当时我们正处于西班牙王位继承战争中——这是我们在17世纪中期到18世纪末之间进行的无数战争之一，好吧，也就是基本上与法国争夺霸权的战争，对你来说，就像是一场庞大的世界大战，我想是的。而且，信不信由你，葡萄牙实际上一直是法国的盟友。什么？所以，是的，我知道，我知道我们有一些葡萄牙听众，也许他们可以解释一下。这种行为太令人震惊了。如果他们是“历史的余烬”俱乐部的成员，他们应该在Discord聊天室里
themselves on the discord chat and explain their conducts because at the beginning of this war portugal is allied with France. Now. That's ruined my Christmas. England gets most of its wine, obviously, from France. So it's sort of shipped over the channel and stuff. But obviously, because we're at war with the French, we're not getting so much wine and so on. So people are looking for alternative suppliers.
公开声明并解释他们的行为，因为在这场战争开始时，葡萄牙是法国的盟友。这可毁了我的圣诞节。英国的大部分葡萄酒显然都是从法国进口的，是通过海峡运过来的等等。但显然，因为我们正与法国交战，我们无法获得那么多葡萄酒等等，所以人们正在寻找替代供应商。
Is that because there's an official state boycott from France? No, I don't think so. Or is it because we're patriotically refusing to drink it? I think it's just more, yeah, I think it's sort of... Hassle. Hassle, patriotism. I don't think you could even enforce, I mean, there's obviously lots of, most of the hate is smuggling. So whether a boycott could even be that strictly enforced.
这是因为法国有官方的国营抵制吗？不，我不这么认为。还是因为我们出于爱国主义拒绝饮用它？我觉得更像是……麻烦。麻烦，爱国主义。我觉得你甚至无法执行——我的意思是，显然有大量的、大部分的憎恶都是走私。所以这种抵制是否能得到如此严格的执行都是个问题。
And Dominic, we have an episode on smuggling coming up. We do, very exciting. So we'll be discovering the answer to that question in the New Year and our smuggling coming up we do very exciting so we'll be discovering the answer to that question in the new year in our smuggling episode but um english travelers have already been to portugal to suss out the wine trade there so in 1678 a liverpool wine merchant sent two representatives to a place called viana del castello which is just north of oporto or porto and um they went to a this would please you tom they went to an abbey yeah called lamego which is in the um the sort of port valleys the great valleys of the kind of duro um and the abbot there gave them what they called a very agreeable sweetish and
多米尼克，我们有一期关于走私的节目即将播出。是的，非常令人兴奋。所以我们将在新年的走私节目中揭晓这个问题的答案。不过，英国旅行者此前已经去过葡萄牙探查那里的葡萄酒贸易。因此，在1678年，利物浦的一位葡萄酒商派了两名代表前往一个叫维亚纳堡（Viana do Castelo）的地方，它就在奥波托（Oporto，即波尔图）的正北方。他们去了一个——这会让你高兴的，汤姆——他们去了一个修道院，是的，叫拉梅戈（Lamego），位于杜罗河（Douro）的波特酒山谷和伟大山谷中。那里的住持给他们提供了一种他们称为“非常宜人的微甜且”
extremely smooth wine which they have fortified with grape spirit so so it's a fortified wine so it's port and they say oh this is very nice and they buy the whole lot of the abbey's stocks wow that is enthusiasm isn't it yeah and bring it home so there's already they already know that there's some good stuff out there and because it's fortified it will last longer and survive the sea voyage better so it's also better for taking to the colonies of course, of course. Interestingly. So 1703, the Portuguese don't like being allied to the French. This shows them in a very good light. Yeah, they shouldn't. And they're keen to change sides.
极其顺滑的葡萄酒，他们用葡萄烈酒对其进行了加强。所以这是一种加度葡萄酒，也就是波特酒。他们说：“哦，这太好了！”然后把修道院的库存全买了下来。哇，真是充满热情，对吧？是的，然后把它带回了家。所以他们已经知道那里有些好东西了。而且因为它是加度酒，所以它能保存更长时间，更好地经受住海上航行的考验。当然，它也非常适合带到殖民地去，理所当然。有趣的是，1703年，葡萄牙人不喜欢与法国结盟。这让他们显得非常正面。是的，他们不应该结盟。而且他们急于倒戈。
And the guy who is Britain's ambassador to Portugal is a man called Sir John Methuen, who is also who combines this job, interestingly, with being Lord Chancellor of Ireland. Oh, that's an obvious job pairing. Well, a sort of boris johnson cabinet pairing isn't it yeah you're minister for equalities and also minister trade minister yeah exactly it's very much a kind of 21st century kind of appointment but i mean possibly easier to do in the 21st century than the early 18th century yes i should imagine saying i mean the bay of biscay i mean it's a rough sea yeah you're not going to be wanting to be sailing between like as we will find out when we come to my choice on a regular basis in the second half of this podcast you know
而英国驻葡萄牙大使是一个名叫约翰·梅休因爵士（Sir John Methuen）的人。有趣的是，他兼任这一职务和爱尔兰大法官。哦，这真是一个显而易见的职位搭配。嗯，这就像鲍里斯·约翰逊内阁的职位搭配一样，对吧？你是平等大臣兼贸易大臣，没错，这非常具有21世纪的任命风格。不过，我觉得在21世纪可能比在18世纪初更容易做到这一点。是的，我猜也是。我是说比斯开湾——那可是风高浪急的大海，你不会想经常在两地之间航行——正如我们在这期播客的后半部分讲到我的选择时会发现的那样，你知道
why i think you would like this tom do you know where sir john methi when he was from uh wilshire he was from wilshire he was from bradford-on-avon oh was he yeah wonderful but do you know what jonathan swift said about him? Something rude, I imagine. A profligate rogue. Possibly involving poo. A profligate rogue without religion or morals, cunning enough, but without abilities of any kind. Swift would be so good to have around at the moment. He'd be a great guest for this podcast.
为什么我觉得你会喜欢这个吗，汤姆？你知道约翰·梅休因爵士是哪里人吗？嗯，威尔特郡。他来自威尔特郡，他来自阿冯河畔布拉ッド福德（Bradford-on-Avon）。是吗？太棒了。但你知道乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）对他是怎么说的吗？我想不是什么好话。一个放荡不羁的流氓。可能还涉及便便。一个既无宗教信仰也无道德底线、狡猾有余但毫无能力的放荡流氓。现在身边能有斯威夫特这样的人可真好。他会是这期播客的绝佳嘉宾。
That'd be wonderful. He'd be rude about us. He's dead, so he can't come on. So anyway, Sir John negotiates this treaty with the portuguese called the port wine treaty where they basically say they'll switch sides uh british the english will sell wool and cloth to the portuguese tax very medieval very medieval and we will uh buy wine from portugal and we'll put less duty on it than wine that comes from France, a third less duty. So this is tremendously good news for people who like port.
那太棒了。他会对我们出言不逊。他已经死了，所以他来不了。不管怎样，约翰爵士与葡萄牙人谈判达成了这个条约，被称为《波特酒条约》。他们基本上达成协议：英国人向葡萄牙人出售羊毛和呢绒，征税——非常中世纪，非常中世纪；而我们将从葡萄牙购买葡萄酒，并且对其实施比从法国进口的葡萄酒更低的关税，少三分之一的关税。对于喜欢波特酒的人来说，这绝对是个极好的消息。
And then the next few years, you get the establishment of so many of these kind of classic English port houses. You see them in Villanova da Gaia on the other side of the river from Porto. So Taylor's, Graham's, Coburn's, Sand Sandymans all these kind of great houses yeah yeah um have you ever been to Porto Tom no I haven't I'd love to go I've actually only been to Portugal once it's number one on my list of places I want to go to Portugal is a very fine country I think stopped off in Lisbon this one is a fantastic which I thought was beautiful. And the whole of Portugal, it's just waiting to go. Yeah. So there's a place in Lisbon called the Port Wine Institute.
在接下来的几年里，你会看到许多这样经典的英国波特酒厂建立起来。你可以在波尔图河对岸的加亚新城（Villanova da Gaia）看到它们：泰谈（Taylor's）、格兰姆（Graham's）、科伯恩（Coburn's）、桑德曼（Sandeman）所有这些伟大的酒庄，是的，是的。你以前去过波尔图吗，汤姆？不，我没有，我很想去。我其实只去过一次葡萄牙，它在我最想去的地方清单上名列前茅。葡萄牙是个非常棒的国家。我曾在里斯本停留过一次，
And it's basically like a gentleman's club. A little nod back to our gentleman's clubs episode. And you can go in there and they've got like a huge wine list, which is just ports. Well, I imagine as a member of Brookses. It's very good. They welcome you with open arms. It's very good. Yeah, they'll love you, Tom.
我觉得那里美极了。整个葡萄牙，都正等待着人们去探索。是的。里斯本有一个地方叫波特酒研究所（Port Wine Institute）。它基本上就像一个绅士俱乐部，向我们的绅士俱乐部那期节目致敬。你可以进去，那里有一份巨大的酒单，全都是波特酒。嗯，作为一个布鲁克斯俱乐部（Brooks's）的会员，我想象那里非常棒。他们会张开双臂欢迎你。非常棒。是的，他们会喜欢你的，汤姆。
Especially if you go in your nice suit that you wore to Brooks's, which I think is a bespoke suit, isn't it? It is, yeah. Yeah, if you go in your bespoke suit, I think they'll be very impressed. I think they've got your books in Portugal, don't they?
特别是如果你穿着去布鲁克斯俱乐部时那套漂亮的西装去的话，我想那是一套定制西装，对吧？是的，没错。是的，如果你穿着定制西装去，我想他们会印象深刻的。他们在葡萄牙有你的书，对吧？
Are they translated into Portuguese? Yeah, some of them. I remember going into... That must have made your day. So not long after I'd first met you, we went to Lisbon on holiday and we went into this gorgeous bookshop you know old-fashioned bookshop and my heart apps sank like a stone because they had almost like a whole wall of rubicon or persian fire it's not enough that you succeed your friends will fail it was awful. Ruined the holiday. Anyway, back to the Methuen Treaty.
它们被翻译成葡萄牙语了吗？是的，有些翻译了。我记得走进……那一定让你的一天都变得美好了。就在我刚认识你不久后，我们去里斯本度假，走进了一家华丽的书店——你知道的那种老式书店——我的心一下子沉到了谷底，因为他们几乎有一整面墙摆的都是《卢比孔河》或《波斯之火》。光是你成功还不够，你的朋友们还得失败。这太糟糕了。毁了整个假期。不管怎样，言归正传，回到《梅休因条约》。
It's very successful. So by 1717, Portuguese wines account for two-thirds of all the wines imported into England. And do you know how many wines in England were French? Five percent. Four percent, Tom. Four percent. Four percent.
它非常成功。因此到1717年，葡萄牙葡萄酒占了进口到英格兰的所有葡萄酒的三分之二。你知道英格兰有多少葡萄酒是法国产的吗？百分之五。百分之四，汤姆。百分之四。百分之四。
Very poor. How patriotic is that? Very patriotic. Very impressive. So poor became, in the 18th century, it was known as the Englishman's drink. And was this good for Portugal as well? Very good, because they're making loads of money.
少得可怜。这有多爱国？非常爱国。令人印象深刻。因此在18世纪，波特酒被称为“英国人的饮料”。这对葡萄牙来说也是好事吗？非常好，因为他们赚了好多钱。
Yeah, they're giving lots of people employment and they're very happy. So 18th century, Britain is kind of booming, becoming the economic superpower. Yeah. So yes, I guess it's good. Spending all our money on Port. So social clubs, obviously we've talked a lot about clubs
是的，他们给很多人提供了就业机会，他们非常高兴。所以18世纪的英国正在蓬勃发展，成为经济超级大国。是的，所以我想这挺好的。把我们所有的钱都花在波特酒上。因此，社交俱乐部——显然我们在最近的几期节目中谈了很多关于俱乐部的话题，因为当然，我们有自己的俱乐部。但是这些俱乐部，我不知道，我觉得这是我们应该在“历史的余烬”俱乐部中引入的一项创新，因为俱乐部会吹嘘他们的会员是所谓的“三瓶男”。所以“三瓶男”不像我弟弟，是一个能在一坐之间喝下三瓶波特酒而又不会丢脸的人。
in recent episodes because, of course, our own club. But the clubs, I don't know, I think this is an innovation that we should introduce in the Rest Is History Club because clubs would tout their membership of what we'll call three-bottle men. So a three-bottle man, unlike my brother, was a man who could drink three bottles of port in one sitting without disgracing himself.
因此，剧作家谢里丹（Sheridan）就是一个“三瓶男”。他是布鲁克斯俱乐部的会员。小皮特（Pitt the Younger）也是。所以他们都在布鲁克斯俱乐部狂饮三瓶波特酒。三瓶波特酒。你知道雪利酒（Sherry）是怎么和这个扯上关系的吗？
So the playwright Sheridan, he was a three-bottle man. He was a member of Brookses. As was, well, as was Pitt the Younger. So it was Pitt the Younger. Yeah. So they were all in Brookses, necking three bottles of port. Three bottles of port. And how does, do you know how Sherry ties in with this?
嗯，雪利酒来自西班牙。它不是来自葡萄牙。是的，没错，赫雷斯（Jerez）。赫雷斯，完全正确，是的。但我很好奇，这是否是一种类似的情况？也许我们可以调查一下。嗯，这也是一种加度葡萄酒，对吧？但它的确是，而且英国商人和西班牙的供应商之间也有着类似紧密的联系。也许我们——我们绝对应该做一期播客。推特上的人和其他人已经多次对我们说，我们应该做一期关于饮料的播客。
Well, Sherry's from Spain. It's not from Portugal. Yeah, it is. Jerez. Jerez, exactly, yeah. But I wondered, was it a kind of similar thing maybe we can investigate that well it's a similarly fortified wine isn't it but it is and there's a kind of similar close link between english traders and yeah the suppliers in in spain maybe they're we could we should definitely do a podcast it's been said to us several times by people on twitter and so on that we should do a podcast on drinks
对，关于葡萄酒，关于茶。对，好吧，那就做一期关于饮料的播客。关于葡萄酒，关于茶。好的。因为它们有着迷人的历史。所以你看。正如听众所能看出的那样，在真正开始制作之前，我们可能需要做一些研究。确实如此。但我同意。
yeah on wine on tea on yeah okay well let a podcast on drinks. Yeah. On wine, on tea. Yeah. Okay. Because they have fascinating histories. So there you go. As a listener will be able to tell, we probably need to do some research before we actually embark on that. That's true. But I agree.
我的意思是，这是一个迷人的主题。很好。而且就像我说的，基本上，我只要喝上一小口波特酒就会……是的。你可不是“三瓶男”。我不是。所以，当你发表关于波特酒的精彩宏论时，我其实在查约翰逊博士的那句名言。
I mean, that is a fascinating theme. Good. And I mean, as I've said, I basically, I can, a sip of port and I get. Yeah. You're not a three bottle. I'm not. So while you while you were giving this wonderful disposition on port, I was actually checking the Dr. Johnson quote.
但你刚才没在听。不，我在听。我在进行多任务处理。真正的话语是：“克莱瑞酒（Claret）是给男孩喝的液体，波特酒是给男人喝的。但渴望成为英雄的人必须喝白兰地。”哦，所以你也许应该把白兰地也算作我们未来的一个主题。好的，多米尼克，那真是太迷人了。我刚才提到了比斯开湾，以及那里的海浪是多么汹涌，坐船横渡比斯开湾的晕船是多么严重。这与我选择的周年纪念日——1831年——不谋而合。
But you weren't listening. No, I was. I was multitasking. And the actual quote is Claret is a liquor for boys, port for men. But he who aspires to be a hero must drink brandy. Oh, so you should maybe include one brandy as well. We yes on our future subject okay well that was fascinating dominic and um i mentioned uh the bay of biscay um and how violent the waves can be there um how bad the seasickness that you get sailing in a ship across the bay of biscay and that ties in with um my choice of an anniversary, which is 1831.
那是查尔斯·达尔文从普利茅斯湾出发，驶入大西洋，经由比斯开湾南下，乘坐“贝格尔号”（Beagle）启航。所以我们将在中场休息后继续讲述达尔文乘坐“贝格尔号”启航的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。——休息回来后，我们将继续讲述达尔文乘坐“贝格尔号”启航的故事。想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票吗？请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。汤姆·霍兰德为查尔斯·达尔文乘坐“贝格尔号”的航行做好了极好的铺垫。现在，当然，汤姆，你知道查尔斯·达尔文是个伟大的萨洛皮安（Salopian，即什罗普郡人），和我一样，是什罗普郡的儿子。是的，我知道。所以我想起什罗普郡，我认为有四大名人。
And it's Charles Darwin setting off from Plymouth Sound out into the Atlantic, down through the Bay of Biscay on the Beagle. So we'll come to Darwin setting sail on the Beagle after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. to Darwin setting sail on the Beagle after the break. Want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets? Head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland has set the scene very nicely for the voyage of Charles Darwin on the Beagle. Now, of course, Tom, you know that Charles Darwin was a great Salopian, like me, a son of Shropshire. Yes, I do. So I think Shropshire, I think there are the big four.
人们谈论的四大名人是：查尔斯·达尔文。罗伯特。克莱夫，印度的克莱夫。卡罗尔·戴克（Carol Decker）。塔保乐队（T'Pau）的卡罗尔·戴克。是的。好的。
There are the big four that people talk about. There's Charles Darwin. There's Robert. There's Clive, Clive of India. There's Carol Decker. There's Carol Decker of Tapao. Yeah. Okay.
还有山姆·鲁克（Sam Brook）。还有我。是的。好吧。没有对克莱夫、T'Pau的粉丝或你本人不敬的意思，但在我看来，在这四个人中，
And Sam Rook. And there's me. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And Sam Brook. And there's me. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, no offense to, no offense to Clive, fans of T'Pau or you, but I think of those four, I think of those four,
查尔斯·达尔文大概是顶级的萨洛皮安。顶级的萨洛皮安。我的意思是，查尔斯·达尔文是一个巨大、巨大的人物。他之所以成为一个巨大的人物，显然是因为进化论之类的东西、物种起源以及所有这些。我绝对认为我们应该做一期关于达尔文的播客，也许具体谈谈“贝格尔号”的航行。因为达尔文曾说过，远征“贝格尔号”是他一生中最重要的事情。在他离开去乘“贝格尔号”之前，他基本上是一个正在接受培训准备成为神职人员的人。所以他出身于一个富裕的背景，并不太确定自己该做什么。所以我想这有点像今天那些出身优渥、受过良好教育却又不太清楚自己该做什么的人。我的意思是，他们会做什么？他们全去当管理咨询顾问或者别的什么了。而在当时，基本上你就会去当神职人员。因为当神职人员算是一个不错的职业。
Charles Darwin is probably top, top Serapion. Top Serapion. I mean, Charles Darwin is a massive, massive figure. And he's a massive figure obviously because of um theory of evolution all that kind of stuff origin of species everything and i absolutely think that we should do a podcast um on darwin and perhaps specifically on the
你会有一个不错的牧师住宅。你会有时间追求你的爱好，而在达尔文的例子中，这些爱好基本上围绕着：首先是自然历史——他是一个狂热的甲虫爱好者，他热爱收集甲虫；他……是一位伟大的植物学家——我的意思是，他热爱这一切。我想起另一个来自什罗普郡的人，多米尼克·维尔弗雷多（Dominic Wilfredo），他对甲虫、化石和收集东西也非常感兴趣。不管怎样，就是这样。
voyage of the beagle because um it darwin went on darwin said by far it was that the Voyage of the Beagle was by far the most important event in his life. Because before he left on the Beagle, he was basically a man who was in training to become a clergyman. So he was from a kind of prosperous background, wasn't entirely sure what to do. So I suppose a bit like today, kind of posh people with good educational backgrounds who don't quite know what to do. I mean, what do they do? They go to the way it's all management consultants or something. Back then, basically, you become a clergyman. So because a clergyman was kind of it was it was a nice job.
他可能排在达尔文之后。这完全是个题外话。是的，好吧。所以，达尔文对自然历史非常感兴趣，但他最近也对地质学产生了兴趣。这是一个
You'd have a nice rectory. You'd have time to follow your pursuits and in darwin's case those pursuits basically revolved around first of all natural history so he was a great enthusiast for beetles he loved kind of you know collecting beetles um he uh great botanist i mean he loved it all i thought somebody else who came from shrewsbury who was uh dominic wilfredo he was very interested in beetles, in fossils, in collecting things. Anyway, there you go.
地质学研究处于爆炸性萌芽期的时代。人们前往德文郡、威尔士或苏格兰的荒野，绘制岩石的历史地图。达尔文对此着迷不已。真的，这就是他想奉献一生的事业。但是那些能让他从事自然历史或地质学职业的学术职位并不存在。所以本质上，神职人员是唯一的途径。
He probably comes second to Darwin. That's a complete sidetrack. Yeah, okay. So, Darwin's very interested in natural history, but he's also very recently become interested in geology. And this is a time
因此他对此感到有点沮丧。理想情况下，他不想成为一名神职人员。他想把一生奉献给研究……被称为“贝格尔号”的船上担任类似“绅士伴侣”的角色。这位绅士是一个名叫罗伯特·菲茨罗伊（Robert Fitzroy）的人，他是“贝格尔号”的船长。他出身无可挑剔。他是一个严厉的托利党人。这是一个政治动荡剧烈的时期，因为关于《改革法案》的巨大辩论贯穿了整个1831年的议会。他是卡斯尔雷勋爵（Lord Castlereagh）的侄子，后者曾任外务大臣，曾与维也纳会议进行谈判，不受拜伦的喜爱，并且因臭名昭著的自杀——割喉而死。菲茨罗伊对此感到紧张，
where the study of geology is kind of explosive infancy. People are going out into the wilds of Devon or Wales or Scotland, and they're mapping out the history of rock. And Darwin is obsessed by this. And really, that's what he wants to devote his life to. But the kind of the academic posts, the careers that would enable him to follow a career in natural history or in geology aren't open. So essentially clergy is the only way in.
因为他担心抑郁症是否会遗传，而他特别担心的原因是，“贝格尔号”上一任前往南美洲（这也是“贝格尔号”计划前往的地方）的船长，在到达麦哲伦海峡时，发现那里太令人沮丧和无聊了，于是他开枪自杀了。天哪。这可真算不上什么推荐。所以菲茨罗伊对此感到紧张。他不想成为船上唯一的绅士，因为作为一名绅士，他不能邀请非绅士的人与他共进晚餐。
So he's feeling kind of a bit depressed about that. Ideally, he'd like not to become a clergyman. He'd like to devote his life to studying the called the Beagle as basically a kind of gentleman's companion. Who's the gentleman is a man called Robert Fitzroy, who is the captain of the Beagle. And he is he's very he's of impeccable background. He is he's a stern Tory. And this is a time of great political convulsion because the massive debate about the Reform Act that's going, you know, roiling Parliament all through 1831. He is the nephew of Lord Castlereagh who was the foreign secretary um negotiated with the congress of vienna not popular with byron yeah um and who notoriously committed suicide so slit his throat and fitzroy is nervous
那会非常痛苦。而计划是，这将是一次为期两年的航行，旨在绘制南美洲的海岸线，甚至可能更长，甚至环游世界——而事实上，他们也确实这么做了。事实上，这是一次为期五年的航行。他……所以他想要一个同伴，这基本上是首要考虑因素。除此之外，因为他们要去这些拥有奇异植物、奇异动物、奇异地质的陌生土地，最理想的人选是那种能够满足所有这些条件的人。而达尔文基本上是最完美的人选。他有着正确的社会地位，并且……（你知道的）他拥有正确的科学专业知识。不过他是一个很爱交际的人吗，汤姆？他确实是一个
about this because he's worried that you know does is depression something that runs in the family and the reason he's particularly worried about this is that the um the captain of the Beagle who had gone on the previous voyage down to South America which is where the Beagle is planning to go um he'd got to the McGillen States and he'd he'd found it so depressing and boring that he'd shot himself. Oh, God. That's not really a recommendation. So Fitzroy is nervous about this. He doesn't want to be the only gentleman on the boat because as a gentleman, he can't invite people who aren't gentlemen to dine with him.
很爱交际的人，但他是个辉格党人，对吧？所以……他们可以就政治争论一番。嗯，这是一个政治辩论激烈的时期，所以这是一个阴影。但在达尔文签约之前，还悬着各种各样的阴影。第一个问题是他的父亲不同意。他的父亲认为这相当于去过“间隔年”（gap year）或者别的什么。你知道，“别去泰国或者别的什么地方在海滩上抽大麻，找个体面的工作，理个发吧”——就是这种态度。而达尔文的叔叔意识到了这次机会所代表的意义——这有多么完美，以及它如何与达尔文的所有兴趣完美契合。
So that would be miserable. And the plan is that this is going to be a two year voyage to kind of map out out the coastline of south america perhaps even longer perhaps go around the world which in in the in the event is what they do in the event it's a five-year voyage um he is uh so he he wants a companion and that's basically the prime consideration but on top of that because they're going to these um strange lands with strange flora strange fauna strange geology um the ideal is someone who could um tick all those boxes and basically darwin is the most perfect person imaginable he's of the right social standing and he's of um you know he's got the right kind of scientific expertise and is he quite a gregarious person though tom he is quite a
所以他基本上大力推动了这件事，达尔文的父亲也被说服了。下一个问题是，达尔文急忙赶到伦敦去见菲茨罗伊，菲茨罗伊却说：“哦，我已经把这个位置提供给我的一个朋友了。很抱歉，但你是候补第一人选。”达尔文陷入了绝望和绝对的痛苦之中。他本来已经完全下定决心要去了。然后第二天，菲茨罗伊跑过来对他说：“我的朋友不想去了。”这全都在伦敦发生。这一切的背景都是威廉四世的加冕典礼，以及关于改革是否应该通过的巨大激烈的政治辩论。所以这是一个极其激动人心的时刻，也是一个……辉格党人和托利党人之间的分歧达到最白热化的时刻。
gregarious person but he's a wig right so um so they can have arguments about politics well this is this is a time of heated political debate so that's that's a shadow but that there are all kinds of shadows that hang over um before darwin gets signed up the first problem is that his father doesn't approve his father thinks that this is equivalent of you know going off on a gap year or something um you know don't go off you know don't go off to thailand or something to smoke pot on a beach you know get a decent job get a haircut it's that kind of attitude and it's um it's darwin's uncle who recognizes the opportunity that this you know that this presents and how perfect it is and how absolutely wonderfully it maps onto all Darwin's interests.
所以这有点像……一个脱欧派和一个留欧派不得不一起在一艘船上待五年，比如奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）和A·C·格雷林（AC Grayling）。是的，完全是这样。那会是个很棒的电视节目。不过……我想也许是因为达尔文太渴望去了，也许是因为菲茨罗伊太渴望有一个想去的人陪着他，他们基本上……同意合得来了。并且双方商定达尔文将随行。所以这一切都非常令人兴奋。
And so he basically kind of pushes it and Darwin's dad is one round. The next problem is Darwin goes rushing down to London to meet Fitzroy, who says, oh, I've offered it to a friend of mine. Sorry, but you're next in line. And Darwin is thrown into despair, absolute misery. He'd kind of completely committed himself to going. And then the next day, Fitzroy comes around and says, my friend doesn't want to do it. And this is and this is all this is all in London. It's all against the backdrop of the coronation of William IV. And this kind of great convulsive political debate about should reform go through so it's a time of immense excitement and it's a time where uh disagreements between Whigs and Tories would be at their most electric
因此，达尔文现在必须做好准备。他必须让自己做好准备。于是他在英格兰四处奔走，向所有的朋友告别，与各种能够为他提供专业知识的学者交谈。因此，他购买了最新型号的显微镜。他购买了最好的猎枪，因为当然，自然历史至关重要的一部分就是射杀动物、剥皮然后做成标本。所以在此时，剥制标本是自然历史至关重要的一部分。他投资购买了一份《地质学原理》，这是查尔斯·赖尔（Charles Lyell）的第一卷著作，这是一部具有开创性的文本，它认为
so it's you know it's kind of like a Brexit a Brexiteer and a and a Remainer having to go on a ship for five years together Nigel Farage and AC Grayley yes exactly it's a great TV show that but um I I think maybe because because Darwin is so desperate to go, maybe because Fitzroy is so desperate to have, you know, someone go with him who wants to go, they basically, they kind of agree to get on with each other. And it's agreed that Darwin will go. So that's all very exciting.
地球并非像《圣经》所暗示的那样由洪水和大劫难塑造的，事实上，地质变化的过程是极其极其缓慢的、极其极其深远的。这对于达尔文在五年航行期间将产生非常非常重大的影响，因为他将反思这种深刻的变化过程。显然，他开始将这些地质学领域的原理应用到自然历史领域中，这是构成他进化论思想的关键部分。所以他把所有的东西都准备好了。
So Darwin now has to get ready. He has to ready himself. So he hares around England saying goodbye to all his friends, talking to various scholars who can kind of provide him with expertise. So he buys the most up to date microscope. He buys the best shotguns because, of course, a crucial part of natural history is shooting animals, skinning them and then stuffing them. So taxidermy is a vital part of of natural history at this point um he invests in a copy of the principles of geology which is the first volume um by um charles lyell uh which is this kind of groundbreaking text which argues
然后他被菲茨罗伊带去参观“贝格尔号”。他们从伦敦出发，乘坐蒸汽客轮穿过肯特郡，沿着南部海岸航行，抵达德文port（Devonport）。在这里，达尔文的自信心受到了下一次打击，因为“贝格尔号”结果非常狭小。那么，究竟有多大呢？“贝格尔号”——我在这里记下来了，让我看看——它是90英尺长、24英尺宽。里面有两个小船舱，其中一个是他们必须共用的。基本上达尔文个子挺高，所以要把自己塞进吊床里是很困难的。所以他心里想：“哦，两年，三年，我真的想这么做吗？”他犹豫了好几天，然后心想：“哦，不，见鬼，我当然想！”接着他就变得和以前一样充满热情了。
that uh rather than the earth having been shaped by you know floods and apocalypses as the bible suggests that actually the processes of geological change are incredibly incredibly slow incredibly incredibly profound and this will be very very important for darwin over the course of the five-year voyage because he will be reflecting on just how profound the processes of change can be and obviously he starts applying these principles from the field of geology to that of natural history and that's kind of a crucial part of what will inform his theory of evolution um so he's getting all his stuff together um and uh he he gets taken by um by Fitzroy then to go and look at the Beagle so they go from London they go on a kind of steam packet around Kent along the south coast and they arrive at Devonport and this is where the kind of the next blow to
日子一天天过去，他一直在四处奔忙采购所有的装备。他必须抵达……在普利茅斯集合，船将从那里起航，他们原定于11月5日——也就是盖伊·福克斯节（Guy Fawkes Day）起航。多米尼克在10月24日到达那里。外面刮着绝对可怕的风暴，风一阵接一阵地狂刮，出发日期不得不取消。风暴整整持续了整个11月。然后在11月21日，其中一个水手——船上一共有73人——其中一人被风吹落水并淹死了。达尔文经历了一场巨大的恐慌发作，你知道的，后来在他的一生中，达尔文经常容易恐慌发作，这种奇怪的胃部不适一直折磨着他的一生。而这是他恐慌发作的早期表现。
Darwin's confidence comes because the Beagle turns out to be really tiny so how big how big is the beagle uh it is i've noted it down here let me see it's 90 feet by 24 and there are there are two cap two tiny cabins one of which you know which they will have to share and basically darwin's quite a big man so he's difficult to get cram himself into the hammock so he's kind of thinking oh you know two years three years do i really want to do this and he kind of havers for a couple of days and he thinks oh no damn it of course i do and then he becomes as enthusiastic as ever um and uh the months go by he's been rushing around sourcing all his gear he's got to arrive um uh in uh in plymouth which the ship is going to sail from um and they're due to sail on the 5th of november so uh guy fawkes day um the domino
他心里想：“我该去吗？我该去吗？”但转念一想，“是的，我当然得去。我必须去。”终于在12月10日，迎来了晴朗的一天，菲茨罗伊说：“好吧，我们要……出发吧，伙计们。”
arrives there on the 24th of october absolutely terrible storms they just kind of blow and blow and blow and the the leaving date has to be cancelled um and they just blow all the way through november and then on the 21st of november one of the sailors so there are there are um 73 people in all are going and one of them gets blown overboard and drowns and darwin has kind of massive panic attack and you know later know, later, all through his life, Darwin will be prone to panic attacks, these kind of strange stomach complaints that grip him all the way through his life. And this is kind of early onset of his panic attacks.
他们全都登船，驶向海峡。天气糟糕透顶。达尔文发现自己根本无法忍受风暴。天哪。他在自己的船舱里一路呕吐不止。
And he's like, oh, should I do it? Should I do it? But again, he thinks, yeah, of course I've got to do it. I've got to do it. Finally, the 10th of December, there's a clear day, and Fitzroy says, okay, we're going to, let's go, let's go, boys.
如果我是菲茨罗伊，我早就把他甩掉了。我的意思是，这太糟糕了。他们只有两个船舱，船只有90英尺长。我的意思是，你最不想要的就是一个挤不进吊床的大个子男人。是的，挤不进吊床。而且还一直在喋喋不休地谈论英国脱欧。
They all board, sail out into the channel. Terrible, terrible weather. And Darwin discovers that he can't cope with storms. God. And it's projectile vomiting all across his cabin.
是的。嗯，他不是在喋喋不休地谈论这个，因为情况正好相反，不是吗？他是留欧派。对的。他在喋喋不休地谈论《伟大改革法案》。是的。嗯，他不是。他是在喋喋不休地谈论地质学什么的。情况正好相反，不是吗？他是留欧派。对的。他在喋喋不休地谈论《伟大改革法案》。是的。嗯，他不是。他是在喋喋不休地谈论地质学等等，反正菲茨罗伊本来也对这些感兴趣。所以第二天，天气太糟糕了，菲茨罗伊调转船头回去了。达尔文去洗了衣服——你知道的，船舱被刷洗干净了——他们都同意把晕船的事忘掉。21日，又是一个晴朗的日子。所以菲茨罗伊说：“好吧，我们走吧。”
If I was Fitzroy, I'd have got rid of him. I mean, it's awful. They've only got two cabins, a 90-foot ship. I mean, the last person you want is like a big man who doesn't fit in the hammock. Yeah, who doesn't fit in the hammock. And also banging on about Brexit.
让我们起航。他们起航了。天气很平静。达尔文上床睡觉。他把自己——屁股朝后——塞进了吊床里。他睡了个好觉。他醒来。他拿过指南针，仔细观察，
Yes. Well, he's not banging on about it, because it's the other way around, isn't it? He's the Remainer. Right. He's banging on about the Great Reform Act. Yes. Well, he's not. He's banging on about geology and's the other way around isn't it he's the remainer he's right he's banging on about the great reform act yes well he's not he's banging on about geology and stuff which which fitzroy is interested in anyway so the next day it's the weather's so bad that fitzroy turns around and they go back and darwin has his clothes washed you know the cabin is scrubbed and um they all agree to forget about the seasickness. 21st, another clear day. So Fitzroy says, okay, let's go.
惊恐地发现他们正在朝英格兰返航。原因是一场可怕的新风暴正在逼近并席卷海峡。因此他们在普利茅斯停靠，风暴袭来，到处都是一片惨淡，他们度过了一个痛苦的圣诞节，因为看起来他们永远也无法起航了。最后，在27日，他们终于出发了，驶入比斯开湾。在比斯开湾，天气糟糕透顶，达尔文日复一日、日复一日地呕吐。但他们继续向南航行，然后他们穿过赤道，到达南美洲，到达火地岛（Tierra del Fuego），到达加拉帕戈斯群岛（Galapagos Islands），穿过太平洋。这是一次为期五年的航行，他们回到了英格兰。达尔文回来时，身上满载着
Let's set off. They set off. The weather is calm. Darwin goes to bed. He fits himself, squeezes himself arse first into his hammock. He has a good night's sleep. He wakes up. He reaches for his compass, studies it,
各种蝴蝶标本，以及他在南美洲收集的巨大地懒骨骼，
and to his consternation realises that they're sailing back to England. And the reason for this is that a terrible new storm is approaching and sweeping down the channel. So they dock in Plymouth, the storm comes in, and all over they have a miserable Christmas because it looks like they're never going to set sail. And then finally, on the 27th, off they set and they they head out and they they get into the bay of biscay and in the bay of biscay it's terrible terrible weather darwin is just kind
美丽的羽毛和各种各样的东西。但最重要的是，他带回了那些将改变世界的思想和理论。非常好。汤姆，我简直不敢相信，这向我证实了你是多么愚蠢，竟然不读帕トリック·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brian）的那些奥布里-马图林（Aubrey-Maturin）系列小说。嗯，我……所以你讲的那个故事，简直纯粹就是帕トリック·奥布莱恩的风格。嗯，我……因为你讲的那个故事简直就是纯粹的帕トリック·奥布莱恩风格。嗯，所以那部我看到的电影，叫什么来着？《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander）？是的。
of sick day after day after day but they keep heading southwards and then they cross the equator they reach south america they reach tierra del fuego they reach the Galapagos Islands they cross the Pacific they had five year voyage they come back to England and Darwin comes back loaded down
那个角色，由……保罗·贝坦尼（Paul Bettany）饰演的……罗素·克劳（Russell Crowe），由保罗·贝坦尼饰演的角色，在我看来很明显是以达尔文为原型的。因为他们去了加拉帕戈斯群岛，不是吗？是的，他们去了。而且那种关系，我想象——我的意思是，因为《贝格尔号航海记》是一本伟大的书。
with all kinds of specimens of butterflies and the skeletons of giant ground sloths that he's picked up in South America and
你知道的，他把它写成了记录。菲茨罗伊也写了一份记录。我想那一定潜藏在那些小说的背景中。我的意思是，它们的时间设定稍微晚一点，但也没有晚很久。我的意思是，这……嗯，这两起事件之间大约有30、40年的时间间隔吧，我想是的。
beautiful feathers and all kinds of things. But above all, he's come back with the thoughts and theories that will come with an idea that will change the world. Very good. Tom, I cannot believe that what this confirms to me is how foolish you are and not reading those Aubrey,
而且，你知道，有一种……他们在拉普拉塔河（River Plate）遭到炮击，我想。英国皇家海军在那里，密切关注那里的英国商业利益，结果他们挨了炮弹。你知道，达尔文，我认为这里面有一种可能性。我想你应该把这作为你的新年决心之一，再去试着读一读。也许吧。我的意思是，菲茨罗伊和达尔文之间最终的关系
Maturin novels of Patrick O'Brien. Well, I, so you tell that story and it's pure Patrick O'Brien. Well, I... Because you tell that story and it's pure Patrick O'Brien. Well, so the film which I saw, what's it, Master and Commander? Yeah.
确实变得相当具有爆炸性。因为实际上，他们爆发的第一次巨大争吵是关于奴隶制的。菲茨罗伊是奴隶制的捍卫者。对。而达尔文，自然出身于一个废奴主义者家庭，对此感到震惊。所以这里面有各种各样引人入胜的动态，引人入胜的方面，我们绝对应该……是的，这是一个非常……而且关于这件事必读的书籍——
The guy, the one played by... Paul Bettany. Russell Crowe, by Paul Bettany, it seemed to me pretty clearly modelled on Darwin. Because they go to the Galapagos Islands, don't they? Yes, they do. And the relationship, I think, I imagine, I mean, because The Voyage of the Beagle is a great book.
我所有的资料都来源于此——是阿德里安·德斯蒙德（Adrian Desmond）和詹姆斯·摩尔（James Moore）合著的达尔文传记。这不仅是关于达尔文最好的传记，也是史上最伟大的传记之一。这是一本绝妙的书。所以我想我们绝对应该考虑做一期这样的节目。非常好。好吧，这是一个愉快的结束语。有大量的阅读资料，是的，我希望这是一期能让你感到庆幸自己没有挤在比斯开湾一艘小船的逼仄船舱里受罪的节目。因为当然，当这期节目播出时，我们可能正处于某种形式的封锁之中。是的，我们可能正处于封锁中。
You know, he writes it up. Fitzroy writes an account as well. I imagine that that must perhaps be lurking in the background of those novels. I mean, they're set a bit later, but not that long. I mean, it's... Well, it's sort of 30, 40 years between the two events, I suppose, isn't it?
所以，不管情况多么严峻，你至少不用和达尔文一起在“贝格尔号”上，看着他在你脸上呕吐。喷射状呕吐。没错。我们明天见，在圣诞十二日或十三日里带来更多精彩的周年纪念日。再见。拜拜。
Yeah. And, you know, there's kind of... They get fired at, I think, in the River Plate. The Royal Navy is there, kind of keep an eye on British commercial interests there, and they get shot at. You know, Darwin, I think there's kind of possibility there. I think you should make it one of your New Year's resolutions to have another stab. Well, maybe. I mean, the relationship ultimately between Fitzroy and Darwin
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听加更节目、抢先听、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistory.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
does become quite combustible because actually the first huge row that they have is about slavery. Fitzroy is a defender of slavery. Right. Darwin, of course, who comes from a family of abolitionists, is appalled by that. So there's all kinds of kind of fascinating dynamics fascinating kind of aspects to that we should we should definitely yeah it's a really and and the book to read on it uh which
变得相当一触即发，因为实际上他们爆发的第一场大争吵是关于奴隶制的。菲茨罗伊是奴隶制的捍卫者。没错。达尔文出身于废奴主义者家庭，对此自然感到震惊。所以这里面有各种引人入胜的动态和各方面有趣的细节，我们绝对应该——是的，这确实是一本非常值得读的书，呃，
i got all the information from this um is uh biography of darwin by adrian desmond and james moore which is not just the best biography of darwin it's one of the great you know all-time biographies it's wonderful book um so i think we should definitely look to do that very good all right okay well that's a jolly note on which to end um lots of reading and yeah and i hope that that's the kind of episode that makes you glad that you're not on a a crowd in a tiny cabin in the bay of biscay because of course by the time this goes out we may be in some form of lockdown. Yeah, we may be.
我所有的信息都是从这里获取的，嗯，这是阿德里安·德斯蒙德和詹姆斯·穆尔合著的达尔文传记，它不仅是关于达尔文最好的传记，也是史上最伟大的传记之一，这是一本极好的书，嗯，所以我认为我们绝对应该考虑做那一期。很好，好吧，这是一个令人愉快的结束语，有很多阅读材料，是的，我希望这一集能让你庆幸自己没有挤在比斯开湾的一个小船舱里，因为当然，当这一集播出时，我们可能已经处于某种形式的封锁中了。是的，我们可能会。
So, you know, no matter how grim it is, you're not on the Beagle with Darwin being sick in your face. Projectile vomiting. Right. We will see you tomorrow for more exciting anniversaries in the 12 days or 13 days of Christmas. Goodbye. Bye-bye.
所以，你知道，不管情况多么严峻，你都没有和达尔文一起在“小猎犬号”上，面对面地忍受他生病时的喷射状呕吐。没错。我们明天见，在圣诞节的12天或13天里回顾更多令人兴奋的周年纪念。再见。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听加长节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。